honestly I mean I'm incredibly wealthy
and I'm happy I am
but how rich you are doesn't define what
kind of a person you are and there are a
lot of rich bags I think you know
like I have a better car than most
people and I have my own airplane which
makes getting to and from places
incredibly easy and it's awesome the
real difference is being free from worry
am I getting able to feed and clothe my
kids what happens if somebody gets sick
am I going to be homeless if I lose my
stupid crappy job can I say no to a
supervisor who is forcing me to work
overtime and not paying me you know all
of the things that sort of ordinary
Americans face I mean there's just not
even in my consciousness
there's wealthy or screwed and it
creates this high-stakes environment
where there really isn't any social or
economic alternative to striving to be a
zillionaire because if you're not a
zillionaire you're basically screwed
that is just nuts that's just stupid to
create a society where somebody cannot
pursue an interesting engaging socially
constructive career because venture
capitalists and private equity guys and
wall street people like me have sucked
all of the value out of the economy for
ourselves
we made a series of decisions that drove
up the wealth of a tiny minority of
people and drove the wealth of everyone
else down theoretically in the services
of creating more growth and it just it
just isn't true if the trend simply
continues in another 30 years the top 1%
of Americans will share something like
35 or 40 percent of national income and
the bottom 50% of Americans will share 5
or 6 percent no one has a stake in
heading that terrible outcome off more
than rich people like me who have
benefited so much from you know our
country and you know its possibilities
when the minimum wage goes up the
economy gets more robust why because
that's how capitalism works when workers
make more money businesses have more
customers and hire more workers
you know when restaurants pay restaurant
employees enough so that even they can
afford to eat in restaurants that's not
bad for the restaurant business that's
good for the restaurant business the
middle class are the true job creators
in a capitalist economy when rich people
tell you that the better off they are
the better off you will be you have to
call on that it's just not true